Pro Palestinian protesters invade the
capital more than 300 demonstrators are
arrested after demanding Israeli
ceasefire by staging s in in a rotunda
in the in the Congress complex look at
this I can't believe what I'm
seeing this is this is so dangerous to
our democracy what these people did here
uh disrupting an official proceeding and
you know parading in government building
I I guess 20 years what do you guys
think 20 18 lock them up at least 18 for
the leader no trial no no we'll just
spend 2 three years Prosecuting them
we'll send search warrants to their
homes we'll bring them back to DC we'll
make them spend tons of money on legal
fees and oh wait no none of this is
going to happen straight to jail they
should have like somebody should
Photoshop in the Q Shaman in there like
someone did that they they they put the
shaman hat on R to or the or the or the
old lady with the American flag that was
not in the capital that was oh that was
somewhere else yeah that one really
frustrates me it's so annoying I see
high-profile people be like look at this
little old lady she was it was in
Michigan or something oh wow like it's
just some random old lady from a
different P like or or or Oklahoma or
something like that CU my brain goes she
wasn't my brain goes right to the I like
in my brain that her and like the shaman
guy are like right next to each other at
the same time Capital yeah the little
lady with American flag she was not at
the capital I mean I could be wrong my
understanding is like that was debunked
a long time ago well January 6 was a
huge disappointment and the
disappointments keep rolling out yeah
but in all seriousness uh uh uh yeah
none of these people should go to jail
for a long period of time I don't care
that they protested in the capital but
we we can see the double standard right
in front of our in front of our eyes
what's going to happen now is the left
is going to come out first of all um I
think Dave Smith came out and made this
point that you know if you're calling
for them to be arrested it was the feds
who did it it was not the leftists who
put you in jail yeah but here's the
problem and I I agree with what he's
saying but this is exactly what they
expect yep the libertarian conservative
post- liberal faction are going to say
no no don't arrest them because we're
good people and they'll go okay you got
it and then if you fart they'll come and
beat the crap out of you and lock you
for two years MH cuz they're not living
by the same agreement right they're
saying we would do it to you but you
shouldn't do it to us and also they feel
justified in what they're doing and that
is sort of never going to go away I I
think the biggest issue is that there's
a two-tier justice system here and it's
obviously obviously Falls around
political lines we don't play by the
same rule book it's it's a real problem
in in the country hardcore leftists will
do anything and everything by any means
necessary that's how they operate
politically and other people just find
that unsavory and they don't want to
they don't want to throw down that way
and so we're always going to be at that
disadvantage and to the average person
because they don't understand that the
media won't report on it in the same way
it won't be it won't be given equal time
or equal explanation by the media you
won't understand that this is happening
there right now so nobody ends up
finding out nobody who isn't politically
initiated will end up knowing yep I do
think this is good though because the
mask has dropped again
and so people who are on the fence
people who are Centrist who think oh I
just don't like the fighting oh you know
XYZ I can't pick a side it'll help them
to really see what's happening here and
why there's such a disparity and how
they should not be voting for
leftists but I don't think it's enough
to change it to be honest I feel like
this group is going to have the same
supporters no matter what hardcore yeah
uh and ultimately the infighting over
whether or not to support Palestine or
Israel is going to disrupt leftist
communities but I don't know that it
will ultimately make them abandon the
party right they'll always unite behind
Democrats I think I think hardcore
leftist will will always unite behind
Democrats I'm sure that there are some
people who are sympathetic to leftist
causes and this is a leftist cause even
though you know I'm certainly
sympathetic to anyone who was blown up
by by the Israeli government unjustly
that's that's horrendous but this is by
and large a leftist cause in the United
States and I hope that people can see
that at least the people leading these
these groups in Washington DC are
completely hypocritical but you know uh
there there's two there's two great
stories in our Traditions there is
chicken little and there is um uh the
boy of cred wolf yes what happened in
Chicken Little did the sky actually fall
down I think the sky did fall down yeah
aren the same story like the kids like
wolf and they're like no there's no wolf
he's like there's a wolf like oh there's
a wolf no there's no wolf then he's like
okay now there actually wolf let get out
of here
and then the Chicken Little was wasn't
it the chicken was like the sky falling
and they're like shut up and they said
it again they shut up and then finally
it fell and no one believed him or
something yep yeah whatever I don't know
all I knowling the plot to Chicken
Little right now when Hamas uh uh runs
this narrative Israel blew up a hospital
a press conference is given where
they're like Israel warned the hospital
they were going to do it and then you
get all these leftists screaming that
Israel did it and then we're like wow I
mean you know we in good faith want to
understand who did this oh and then it
turns out nobody did it
I mean look it it appears that a Hamas
rocket misfired the payload landed in
the parking lot and created a big fire
the hospital is intact hundreds of
civilians did not die they lied again
these people lie all the time so when
they come out and they're like Israel is
doing evil things I go shut your mouths
dude I am so sick of you lying to me to
get me to support war or hundreds of
millions of our dollars being sent to
Gaza at this point I'm just like bro I
don't care I want nothing to do with it
I'm just tired of being lied to by
everybody mhm this is what they do
Rashid T immediately comes out and
claims that Israel blew up a hospital
and people believe it and then the facts
come out a day later and that's of
course oh I mean it's it's it's
considerable damage in the parking lot
there's no crater sure that's the cars
were on fire that's it do they really
even need to exaggerate isn't there
enough chaos and suffering going on over
there all of it is lies I'm sorry I'm
I'm at the point like they show me these
videos and I'm like gee did an
earthquake happen because they have lied
so much I am done listening to them okay
I'm just I'm I'm fed up I'm just I'm the
the hospital thing was so infuriating
because I see you know like Lukowski
posts why are my tax dollars going to
hitting hospitals because the initial
assumption The Wall Street Journal runs
this headline story that you know blast
blows up hospital or whatever and then
it turns out it's like oh wait here's
here's here's video of a rocket misfire
and then we wake up in the morning and
there's footage it's like oh the parking
lot was on fire and they claimed
hundreds died but it's not true but that
story is already out there I mean you
pointed out the Washington Post put it
in their print edition Wall Street
Journal so there are tons of people who
are now always going to be able to have
the image of this headline and that's
ultimately what I think this is the
objective is anyways they it's not to
get truth out there it's to whip you
into a frenzy to support the cause which
is you know one of the grossest parts of
politics in any country but definitely
in America and way worse now in the like
with with war being as in the
information around War being as
immediate as it is you just you just
leak the story you put the story story
out there and yeah sure maybe 5 to 10
20% end up reading the retraction or see
the follow-up headline but that's a
large amount of people a vast number who
will never know that that's not what
happened here and even if you do print a
retraction I mean the thing about war
reporting is that it's all happening so
fast it's very difficult to verify which
means that as the consumer of it you
should be very uh careful about what
you're seeing and what is being told to
you but people don't do that and so by
the time you know the Wall Street
Journal says oh maybe got it wrong
actually seven other things have
happened that they've reported on so it
doesn't really matter that never gets
fully cored yeah it's just going to
further and deepen The Divide in the
United States because now you're going
to have a Hardcore team Palestine and a
Hardcore team Israel who believe
different things happen fundamentally
they do not even have the same narrative
which is true of all conflicting causes
but in this case there's no way to go
back and say this was what happened
definitively because the information
that gets circulated I mean this is a
downside of the internet age and the
internet is ultim
you know a huge blessing in a lot of
cases but in this case it means that
it's moving so quickly you have no way
to verify it and by the time you watched
that one video read that one tweet it's
gone and six other things have replaced
it most days I don't actually think the
internet was a blessing anymore like I
don't like it's is as awful as that
sounds like I don't feel like human
beings were designed to be inundated
with that much information constantly uh
especially when you take into account
your life your work your kids all these
things that take up your time and then
you have these stories which are not
light sto these are not stories about
celebrities or about something in like
cheap in the news this is like really
really lifechanging stuff and you're not
designed to be able to take in all this
information endlessly be able to parse
through all the facts and figure it out
they have to rely on people to do that
but we can't rely on the media to be the
ones to do that openly and honestly this
this is the crazy thing for the entirety
of human history up until the last 80
years or maybe 100
years news was few and far between was
rare or local just very local very local
but barely uh so there was a newspaper
from uh up in Martinsburg I I forgot
where where it was pulled from someone
was telling me about it and it was like
the the one of the front page stories
was that a guy broke his door on his on
his storefront or something like the
newspaper was like Jim broke his door
and you're like oh Jim broke his door
like imagine your community imagine if
your newspaper said like your next door
neighbor's dog got out you'd be like oh
wow that happened again that was news
now it's like every headline news is
like Hitler has returned from the grave
and you know like World War 17 is
happening and they're competing on a
huge scale they need attention from
everyone on Earth it's the same reason
why people are more likely to know who's
running for president than who's
actually running for mayor even though
the mayor makes more decisions about
their Town AB I mean I think you're
right that the Deluge of information is
definitely a hindrance for the internet
and I go back and forth sometimes it is
awful but you know the internet allows
me to work the job I have right now the
internet allows tons T of families to
homeschool their children effectively
the internet allows people to you know
travel and experience the world while
they work remotely and so as much as I
want to hate the internet all the time
we are past the point of going without
it and there are all kinds of things
that uh suffer when we don't have the
infrastructure for the internet I think
about rural communities that don't have
access to you know hospitals or reliable
um emergency service lines partially
because all of that goes through the
internet but I do got to give it up to
the Internet because imagine what life
was like before it when the government
would put out a statement saying Hamas
has blown up a hospital killing hundreds
of people and you were like wow and that
was it yeah I was talking to a friend
about his family and their view of of
Institutions and their view of
Institutions are that institutions are
absolute and it's kind of crazy like the
general idea is if it's said on TV it is
true period the internet is all fake and
that's the that's the world they live in
but that's like a lot of people who are
voting Democrat who are watching MSNBC
and CNN and I think it's an older
generation Because the Internet was more
scary it's not to be as trusted and to
be fair to the internet a lot of crazy
stuff comes up on the internet I mean it
is where uh ideas are fleshed out in a
way that they are not in mainstream
media trust the experts right and and it
asks more of you as the person consuming
the information to be able to make up
your own mind about things I do
understand that right like when I make
that statement that's a more Doomer take
on it like look we're just not but at
the same time when it was just for news
networks deciding what information you
were given you know then you've put all
the power in the hands of the most elite
members of society who will never have
your best interest at heart I just find
that PE people have talked about how
like like in the age of the internet
like we've stop looking at things the
way we did before right like now when
you go to look something up you're hit
with so much that you just at least for
like for me I find that I find it I find
it difficult right to parse through all
the information and if that's difficult
when that's your job it's even more
difficult if you're just somebody who's
trying to stay up on current events
while taking your kids to soccer
practice working your your job that's
just it's a lot to ask of people but
with freedom comes the responsibility
toity yeah it's it's psychologically
fatiguing and it's probably related to
why we have so many anxiety disorders
now when we didn't back in the day you
know the day before the internet because
there's no way to unplug but I like
having electricity and all I like
electricity for sure air conditioning
that's a good one uh with the internet
though I don't think it's as addictive
as the I mean maybe there were people
who were glued to their TV definitely
when major events were happening but the
internet is addictive in a way that uh
mainstream media in the traditional
television or radio format is not and
that has to do the fact that it's
interactive that you have sort of
personally invested yourself if you have
like a social media profile um and it
means that you constantly want to be
checking in on it whereas at one point
you know the news got boring and you
would turn it off and do something else
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 P.M
and become a member over at
timcast.net elusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next
time